knife in his hand
knife in his hand watch crossfire watch
crosstalk newly released body camera
footage shows the moments leading up to
the death of 22 year old christian glass
who was shot and killed by police during
what may have been a mental health
crisis i have to kill some skill
i'm gonna have to kill some skin walkers
can you stay on the phone with me on
june 10th glass called 9-1-1 after
crashing his car he told dispatch he was
stuck and needed help getting out hello
9-1-1
i'm in a vehicle my vehicle got stuck in
a really bad way about three minutes
into the call glass began referencing
skinwalkers which are witches in the
navajo culture do you know the skinwall
cruise matt
they might just go by i might be lucky
okay can i get your date of birth real
quick
oh i'm so lucky
at another point glass tells the 911
operator that she is his light after
he's been frightened by a sound outside
i had a spiritual awakening a few months
ago and came out of my 10 years of
depression and
i've just been
um come please help that's not good time
what's that beat i love you thank you
yeah
i love you seriously
you're my light right now i love you
glass later told dispatch he was an
amateur geologist and had several
weapons inside his vehicle are there any
weapons that you're aware of they
i have i have a weapon on me i will
throw them out the window as soon as an
officer gets here
i have i have two knives
and a hammer
um
and
and a rubber mallet i guess that's the
weapon i'm not dangerous i will keep my
hands completely visible
both cars be advised this party is
stating that he has weapons in the
vehicle with him two knives a hammer and
a rubber mallet he did state that he
would throw them out of the window as
soon as officers got on scene to make
you feel safe responders determined
glass's vehicle was stuck in silver
plume colorado about 50 minutes west of
denver officers from the clear creek
county sheriff's office responded to the
call
come out and talk to us come on dude
we're here to help we're here to help
come on bud please push me out
for more than an hour officers from
multiple agencies attempted to get glass
out of the vehicle you need to step out
of the car now
step out of the car now that's a lawful
order step out of the car you'll be
removed from the vehicle step out now
glass repeatedly told officers he was
scared and did not want to exit his
vehicle at the same time officers voiced
concern about the weapons inside of the
vehicle you already said you have
weapons in the vehicle
because you already said you have
weapons in the car
no do not throw them out do not touch
them do not reach for them he's got a
knife in his
seat right there
okay step out of the car now
1161 at gunpoint
step out of the car now officers
threatened to break down the window if
glass did not step outside
step out of the car now
i will break the window step out of the
car
step out of the car
step out of the car glass insisted he
could not leave the vehicle and made
mention of a mental hospital keep your
hands on the steering wheel then and
don't move you reach for anything we're
gonna have problems
a mental hospital for what we haven't
even been able to have a conversation
with you during the incident colorado
state police said there was no reason to
breach the vehicle
can you ask people
if there's no crime and he's not
suicidal homicide or
great danger and there's no reason to
contact him so
my sergeant said no point in collecting
if he's not a harm to himself or
anyone else then no crime meantime
officers continued to ask glass to leave
the vehicle but he again stated he did
not feel safe
at night
that's why i want you out of the car so
we can have this conversation safely
period that's it this is the only way i
can be safe
what are you talking about when another
officer approached and discussed the
rocks inside of glass's vehicle he
signaled her with a
will you heart to me
what can you tell me about what's going
on
we're trying to help you out you know i
see you're doing the heart thing with
your hands but we love you too we just
want you to be safe additional officers
arrived and tried to calm glass and
persuade him to step outside uh
christian
you don't have any guns or anything that
scares us right
okay
you said on the phone you know when you
called us he said on the phone that he
had knives
okay are they
big knives little knives less than an
hour later glass grabbed a knife when
officers broke down his passenger side
window okay we're popping
dude
knife in his hand
knife in his hand watch crossfire watch
crosstalk
watch crossfire watch crossfire glass
then began to yell out in prayer
please drop the knife
randy you got that door held shut
moments later an officer shot glass five
times after the shooting the clear creek
county sheriff's office released a
statement saying glass was argumentative
and uncooperative during the incident
the release also said glass tried to
stab an officer as police broke down his
vehicle's window he had done nothing
wrong he was just too scared to get out
of his car now glasses family is calling
for criminal charges against the officer
responsible for their son's death we
have made no public statement before now
christian's killing is a stain on claire
creek county and on colorado
it was a murder by a colorado official
in a press conference on tuesday glass's
parents sally and simon glass called for
justice in their son's death it was dark
and he was really worried
he trusted the police to come and help
him
instead
they attack and kill her
the killer shot christian
five times just to make sure
right now the shooting is still under
investigation by the colorado bureau of
investigation for the latest
developments in this story and all
things true crime stay with long crime
network i'm sierra gillespie